alors aujourd'hui on est on est avec le
papa de de Cécile Jonathan livver
d'ailleurs qui a écrit un livre Ccile ma
fille m'a disparu votre fille a disparu
comme n l'a dit Michel est-ce que vous
avez déjà pensé qu'il y avait un lien
entre la disparition de votre fille
Michel fourir pas du tout alors déjà
depuis
longtemps je me disais tant que je ne
connais pas la vérité sur la disparition
de Cécile
euh Michel faoniret serait
un un responsable logique vu sa façon de
aborder des des personnages à
l'extérieur et cetera et puis aussi la
variété de ces ces victimes c'est c'est
absolument affreux et euh mais mais je
je n'étais absolument pas convaincu que
bà ça ça fait un mois un mois que on
sait que la disparitiontion de céciles
est peut-être totalement lié à Michel
firet ne sa que les dates les dates elle
a disparu le 8 juin
et Monique Olivier l'a vu avec
fornirit c'était le 9 le 9 le 9 juin le
9 au soir alors et cile c'était la seule
disparition d'enfants mineurs mineur
en en cette époque en 97
donc et puis quand j'entends le le récit
de de Michel je suis désolé mais je suis
totalement écuré de
revivre ce parcours ce parcours et ce
parcours qui a traîné pendant 18 ans 18
ans sans que les Belges informment les
Français c'est c'était insensé insensé
et tout le travail qui a été fait depuis
et notamment vous
connaissez enfin tous maître Cathy
Richard et énorme avocat très belle
personne
elle a appris au procès de Monique
Olivier cette histoire cette histoire de
de ce qui s'est passé avec fouiret et
cette cette jeune fille elle a était
témoin de de d'une jeune fille de 16 à
18 ans Cécile 17 ans et demi 17 ans et
demi comment on fait pour vivre comme ça
quand quand quand on n pas de réponse et
qu'on sait que sa fille a disparu
comment vous avez vécu toutes ces années
excuse-moi comment vous avez vécu toutes
ces années quand on sait que on n pas de
réponse que sa fille a disparu et que on
n pas de réponse de la justice de de de
alors j'ai j'ai pas une une recette la
la toute première chose c'est Cécile
c'était extraordinairement aimante et
aimée et cet amour pour
elle je je l'exprime depuis sa
disparition tous les jours je lui parle
de tout l'amour que j'ai pour elle euh
au départ je parlais aussi de la colère
mais ça la colère est est sorti moi je
je je donc c'est comme ça que je parle
avec elle en même temps euh euh je suis
totalement disponible pour l'avocat
maître Richard euh euh si elle a besoin
de moi ou pour euh une une activité avec
les les médias qui ont joué un rôle très
important par rapport à la disparition
de ce est-ce que est-ce qu' aujourd'hui
vous êtes vous êtes j'ai pas envie de
dire soulagé mais est-ce que vous dites
au moins on a peut-être des éléments de
réponse est-ce que ça vous soulage ou
est-ce que vous dites au contraire il y
a eu vraiment des des des failles
incroyables et un comme disait Michel il
y a eu des des problèmes qui ont fait
que c'est c'est inadmissible ce qui
s'est passé pour vous Michel c'est oui
c'est pardon c'est deux choses c'est
deux choses je suis totalement écuré par
ce monstre ce monstre euh c'est un
monstre qui était à étrangler il y a a
20 ans
euh ce monstre là mais en même temps si
si le dossier de Cécile trouve
résolution
euh ce sera très important c'est très
important parce que 20 25 ans euh on est
en sur qui vivve peut-être peut-être je
ne sais pas encore peut-être cette
cicatrice qui est là qui se ferme pas
peut-être elle se fermeront peut-être il
y aura un deuil à faire mais
ça je c'est pas de pronostique de ce qui
lui est arrivé ni ce qui va se passer
euh mais c'est deux choses très
importantes une vraie
piste
épouvantable mais en même temps une
piste qui va peut-être mener à la
fermeture de dossier Michel l'enquête a
connu après 27 ans où elle
a où rien ne s'est passé elle vient de
connaître un formidable coup
d'accélérateur parce que tout à l'heure
dans mon récit j'ai oublié de préciser
un ou de détails j'ai parlé de la de la
taille de Michel Fourniret et de de
Cécile Vallin mais
également le le la concomitance des
temps c'estàdire disparition le 8 juin
l'appel de fournirait le 9 juin au soir
et ça correspond à peu près à au délai
de route sachant que fournirait
nutilisit jamais l'autoroute qui prenait
que des nationales et donc il y a 800 et
quelques kilomètres et et ça peut coller
si vous voulez par rapport aux horaires
et j'ajoute encore que Michel Fourniret
avait de la famille en ha Savo en Savoie
et qu'il avait une nièce notamment et
qui connaissait la
région justement il y a il y a beaucoup
d'affaires là qui n'ont pas été résolues
depuis de le début de voilà de la saison
le petit Émile on a pas de nouvelles euh
Gill on a alors déjà il faut se réjouir
effectivement que ce pôle qui a été créé
à nentère de Cold Case ça c'est très
récent en France avant les affaires
étaient abandonnées et là ils reprennent
tout ils sont extrêmement compétents ils
déterrent des anciens procès verbaux et
effectivement en se saisissant de cette
affaire monsieur on espère vraiment
qu'ils vont pouvoir faire éclater la
vérité reprenant les PV et cetera pour
aimer les Lina c'est un peu tôt c'est
c'est les les les enquêteurs du
quotidien qui travaillent là-dessus mais
ce P de colkis a déjà réussi à résoudre
différentes affaires et là franchement
c'est un espoir pour cette enquête
monsieur bah Cather Richard a fait en
sorte que une demande d'acte pour que
Monique Olivier soit interroger oui
alors j'espère que ça se ça se fera vite
parce que je sais qu'il y a déjà deux
cas pour lequel elle va PL des coupable
je suppose hein donc
et j'aimerais maintenant que ça se passe
vite et puis entendre encore ah non non
je peux pas supporter
d'attendre dans dans dans son récit
Monique Olivier se met totalement hors
de cause hein elle ne elle ne dit pas
qu'elle a participé à quoi que ce soit
elle dit simplement ce dont elle a été
témoin et donc elle parlera à mon avis
plus facilement dans la mesure où elle a
pas à se mettre dans le dans la marmite
elle est davantage désireuse aujourd'hui
depuis quelques temps de révéler de
parler de de confesser même si elle est
pas directement protagoniste donc on
peut espérer qu'elle a envie de dire la
vérité sur vraiment ce qu'elle sait de
cette affaire terribleus présent quand
elle a dit la vérité ça lui a coûté cher
oui mais elle l'a ditite déjà dans dans
les trois cas où où de son dernier
procès à la fin elle a demandé pardon
aux familles donc et ça montrit avant on
disait ah ben non je connais pas et puis
elle a quand même
éolu elle a témoigné pour ce que ce que
ce qu'elle a fait et puis euh mais je
veux pas qu' elle fasse la même chose
pour me faire plaisir mais ça ça c'est
c'est bien que elle est pas dans une
disposition de automatiquement caché
dernière dernière chose il faut quand
même prendre les déclarations de Monique
Olivier avec des pincettes parce qu'elle
a aussi tendance à raconter euh des
choses qui sont pas forcément exactes
donc elle noit un peu le poisson dans
euh dans un flot de de de de récit mais
en tout cas pour ce qui est de de cette
affaire de la disparition de de Cécile
Vallin je crois qu'on n jamais été aussi
près d'apprendre enfin quelque chose
savoir ce qui s'est ce qui s'est passé
et en tout cas là elle peut parler sans
être poursuivi h
h CH Oui et puis c'est vrai que depuis
la mort de Michel fournir on sent que
peut-être elle a elle a moins peur et ça
peut être un un espoir de résolution de
incroyable espérons de merci merci
Monsieur Oliv d'être avec nous d'avoir
été avec
nous ma F disparu merci d'avoir été là
merci beaucoup
merci sur C merci à tous